Welcome back to GitHub Awesome. We
scoured GitHub and tracked down 34
self-hosted open-source projects
trending right now. All links in the
description below. Let's get into it.
Aentic inbox is a full self-hosted web
email client with a built-in AI agent
running entirely on Cloudflare workers.
Each mailbox gets isolated into its own
durable object with a local SQLite
database. The agent continuously reads
your inbox, searches threads, and drafts
replies automatically. You just click
approve before anything sends.
Built-in MCP server means clawed code or
cursor can securely access your mailbox,
too. Google killed the maps timeline web
dashboard and moved all location history
exclusively to your phone. Dwarich is
the self-hosted alternative. Take your
Google takeout archive, drop it into
Dwarich, and it instantly plots your
entire life's location history onto a
gorgeous interactive private map,
imports from Strava and GPX files, and
connects to own tracks on your phone to
continuously log your location to your
own server.
Your tasks are scattered across Jira,
GitHub, and random sticky notes. Super
productivity pulls them all into one
unified interface. It's an execution
engine, not just a to-do list. Built-in
time tracking, Pomodoro timers, time
boxing, and a visual schedule panel
where you drag and drop tasks onto a
calendar to plan your week. Strictly
local first and 100% private. No
accounts, no cloud subscriptions, zero
telemetry.
Stop uploading private photos to sketchy
online converters. Ashim is sterling PDF
but for images. 30 plus tools packed
into a single Docker container,
including format conversion, resizing,
and image stitching. The real power
built-in local AI models for background
removal, upscaling via real ESR GAN, OCR
via paddle OCR, and contentaware
resizing using seam carving. Hermes by
now research is a self-improving AI
agent. Hermes control interface gives
you a self-hosted web dashboard for the
entire stack. Browserbased terminal for
direct chat, file explorer for its
workspace, session overview, cron
management for scheduled tasks, live
token analytics, system metrics, and
multi-agent administration.
Paper console is a self-hosted offline
thermal printer appliance. Turn a
physical rotary dial. Press a button and
it prints your daily news, weather, RSS
feeds, calendar, emails, and system
stats straight onto thermal paper. Runs
on a Raspberry Pi and a cheap 58mm
receipt printer. 16 modules assignable
across eight dial channels. Even
includes offline generated games like
Sudoku, Mazes, and choose your own
adventure stories.
Getting photos from wedding guests is
usually a nightmare. people forget the
hashtag or you pay a fortune for a
commercial app. Wedding Share is the
self-hosted solution. Print the provided
QR codes, put them on the dinner tables,
guests scan and instantly upload photos
to your server with no app install
required. Full admin dashboard to
approve or reject before photos go live.
Pycode is a self-hosted platform with 68
hands-on implementation problems ranging
from realu and layer norm from scratch
all the way up to flash attention RHF
flow matching and speculative decoding.
Read the paper, write the code, run the
grader, fix what breaks. Write Python
directly in the browser. The local fast
API backend runs it against a hidden
PyTorch test suite. Zero cloud setup, no
accounts, and no GPU required.
Caliber is powerful, but its web
interface looks like 2005, and syncing
reading progress across devices is a
nightmare. Devourer Reader Server is a
modern Node.js and SQLite backend for
your entire digital library. Point it at
your CBZ, CBR, or EPUB folders, and it
automatically grabs covers, tags, and
metadata from Google Books, ComicVine,
and My Anime list. If you track your
vinyl collection on Discogs, you know
the default site feels dated and slow.
Discographic is a self-hosted companion
app that connects to your Discogs
account and turbocharges it. Syncs your
entire library and caches locally via
one Docker command. Blazing fast
browsing with no more API rate limits.
Deep collection stats, value tracking,
and a random album picker for when you
can't decide what to play.
Tired of paying for buffer or hype fury?
Post eyes is the self-hosted
alternative. 28 plus supported channels
including X, LinkedIn, Instagram, Tik
Tok, Reddit, Blue Sky, Discord,
Masttodon, and WordPress. Full screen
UI, tiptapri text editor, seamless
crossosting, built-in AI with V3 for
video and slide generation, AI optimized
posting times, and dedicated NADN nodes
for complex automation.
Cherry is a cross-platform desktop task
manager built on Tori with one killer
feature, native CalDav compatibility.
Seamlessly syncs with self-hosted
Nextcloud, Radicol, and by call and
works out of the box with Apple
reminders and tasks.org. Subtasks,
progress tracking, repeating routines,
custom tags, everything a power user
needs. Your data stays 100% on your own
infrastructure.
Managing Trafic means wrestling with
deeply nested YAML files. Traffic
Manager is a self-hosted web UI to
manage your entire reverse proxy without
touching YAML. Visually add HTTP, TCP,
or UDP routes. Configure middlewares,
monitor TLS certificates. The killer
feature, a real-time route map showing a
four column visual topology of how your
entry points connect to routes,
middlewares, and services.
Music Seir is a self-hosted music
discovery and request platform built
around LiDAR, connecting Jellyfin,
Navadrome, Last.fm FM and Listenrains
into one unified web interface. Search
the Music Brains catalog, request
missing albums, LiDAR grabs them with
one click. It's also a full web player.
Stream from Jellyfin, Navadrome, local
files with a 10band EQ and automatic
scribbling.
Tired of paying enterprise per user fees
for Notion or Confluence? Docmost is the
self-hosted escape hatch. The editor is
the standout. Buttery smooth real-time
collaboration with no overwrite
conflicts. Native Latex math support and
excellio
and mermaid diagrams built directly in
granular permission spaces, user groups,
inline commenting and full page version
history.
Google Docs and Notion are bloated and
slow. Jot is the radically minimal
alternative. A self-hosted markdown
editor with full support for
collaborative inline comment threads.
Invite your team to review specs, draft
documentation, or brainstorm
architecture directly inside the file
without losing formatting or context.
Distractionfree, lightning fast, runs
entirely on your own server.
Rocksmith 2014 is great for learning
guitar, but dealing with loading
screens, file conversion, and custom DLC
is painful. Slopsmith is a self-hosted
Rocksmith clone running in your browser
or as a standalone desktop app. Point it
at your DLC folder and it generates a
fully playable 3D note highway with
bends, slides, palm mutes, and custom
tabs.
Bookmarking a URL is just saving a
pointer to something that might
disappear.
Linken saves the URL and automatically
captures a full page screenshot and PDF
of the site at the time you save it.
Everything stays searchable, annotable,
and permanently yours regardless of what
happens to the original page. a bookmark
manager that actually preserves what
you're bookmarking.
Fine-tuning LLM has always meant either
waiting a long time or buying more GPU
memory. Unsloth addresses both. Custom
Triton kernels and mathematical
optimizations cut training time in half
while reducing VRAM usage by up to 70%.
The new Unslo Studio adds a web UI for
training and running Quen, Deepseek,
Gemma, and other models without touching
the command line.
Most people have no idea how many
external connections their machine is
making at any given moment. Tapmap reads
your local socket connections, resolves
the IPs using MaxMind GeoLite 2, and
plots every active connection on a live
interactive world map, runs entirely
locally, zero telemetry, and produces a
visualization that is equal parts
fascinating and unsettling.
Dispatch R is an open- source IPV proxy
and stream manager built like a new
member of the R family. Feed it your M3U
playlists, filter thousands of channels,
auto match EPG guides, and assign per
user stream permissions. The killer
feature is HD Home Run emulation. It
pretends to be a physical TV tuner on
your network, so Plex, MB, and Jellyfin
discover it natively as a live TV source
with full DVR recording.
Conduit is a native iOS and Android app
built specifically for your self-hosted
Open Web UI backend, real-time websocket
streaming, markdown rendering with
syntax highlighting, mermaid diagrams,
and latex math inline. The killer
feature is voice call mode. Deep OS
integration means it uses native call
kit on iOS and looks exactly like a
regular phone call with your AI.
Setting up SSO for your home lab with
Keycloak or Hydra is a nightmare. Pocket
ID strips all that complexity away. It's
an ultra lightweight self-hosted OIDC
provider with one twist, zero passwords,
pass keys only. Deploy a Docker
container and sign into Proxmox,
Nexcloud, Graphana, and all your
self-hosted apps with your phone's
biometrics, Touch ID, or a UB key.
Running one AI coding agent is powerful.
Running five simultaneously turns your
terminal into chaos. Agents Mesh is a
fleet command center for AI agents. Spin
up agent pods through a web console,
each with its own isolated git work tree
and sandbox. Drop tickets into a
built-in canbon board, assign them to
different agents, watch them work in
parallel. Agents can message each other,
share context through channels.
Tired of paying for Jira? Scrumboy is
the self-hosted alternative built for
the AI coding era. Canananban boards,
sprints, story points, and real-time
dashboards in a single static leg. Go
binary. Deploy with Docker in seconds.
No onfiles, no TLS headaches, no
database config. Claude Code and other
AI agents connect directly to your
workspace, read their assigned tickets,
and create bug reports automatically
while writing code.
Caliber Web is powerful. It also looks
like it was designed in 2008 and nobody
noticed. Bookbag is a complete groundup
UI redesign that connects directly to
your existing caliber database.
Beautiful cover grids, refined
typography, smooth, responsive layouts.
Developers on Reddit are calling it
going from front end to art. Ships as a
Docker container. Drop it alongside your
existing setup. No migration required.
Database backups are something every
developer knows they should set up and
nobody actually does. Portabase
automates it without ever exposing your
database ports to the public internet.
Drop a lightweight Rust agent next to
your database container and it handles
backups locally and streams them
directly to S3, Cloudflare R2, Google
Drive or your local file system.
Tired of My Fitness Pal locking features
behind a payw wall? Sparky Fitness is
the self-hosted alternative. Nutrition,
sleep, hydration, fasting, and workout
tracking across a web dashboard. Plus
native iOS and Android apps. Syncs with
Garmin and We Things Full Open ID
Connect login for the whole family. Snap
a photo of your lunch or just type what
you ate and it calculates the macros and
logs it automatically.
You ditch Spotify and self-host your
music on Navadrome or Jellyfin. Now you
need a client that actually feels
premium. Fish is a modern cross-platform
desktop music player built as a full
rewrite of Sonix D. Beautiful UI, MPV
and web player backends, synchronized
lyrics, smart playlist editing, and
scrabbling straight to your server. A
retro milkdrop style audio visualizer
reacting to your music in real time
inside the app. What if your music
library just grew itself? Soulbeat
bridges Soulsek and your media library
into a fully automated pipeline. It
analyzes your last FM listening history
to recommend new music, triggers
downloads through the back end, then
tags and organizes everything with
beats. Discover it, download it, file
it. Zero manual work for music hoarders
who want their collection on autopilot.
Void LLM is a self-hosted AI gateway
sitting between your applications and
providers like OpenAI, Anthropic, or
VLM. role-based access control, token
budgets, rate limiting, and
multi-eployment load balancing with
automatic failover. Most AI proxies log
conversations by default. Void LLM never
stores or persists your prompt data.
Sensitive code and private information
never touch disk.
Popra is a self-hosted document
management platform that uses a strictly
tagbased system. Custom tagging rules
that automatically categorize files
based on text extracted directly from
the documents. Email ingestion is the
other standout. Forward an invoice to a
custom address. Popra parses the
attachments, runs full text OCR, and
archives it automatically. Never open
the app.
Documenting your home network manually
is tedious and always out of date. Home
label actively scans your network,
identifies machines and open ports, and
automatically generates an interactive
map of your entire home lab. The
interesting part, optional MCP server
support. Your AI agents can query your
live network topology natively and know
exactly what's running on your home lab
in real time.
Viseron runs via Docker with local ML
handling, object detection, face
recognition, and license plate reading,
all on your own hardware. The 3.5
release added 247 recordings and an in
browser configuration editor which
closes some of the gaps that made
earlier versions harder to manage. A
serious frigot alternative for anyone
who wants to compare options before
committing to a camera setup.